for the last 48 years Dr Joyce Poole has
been eavesdropping on elephant families
learning their language
I speak to elephants
I rumbled to them if they seem upset I
say hello and things
their vocabulary is very large
elephants have over 30 vocalizations
the rumbles the low frequency cores
there are roars
there are trumpets their cries
wants to suck all
right yeah
so that's when it escalates that's when
the circle Rumble didn't work and then
you have to escalate so saying mom put
your leg forward
I'm almost not being very cooperative
there's an ala mother
just like a babysitter
she doesn't have any milk but she can
Comfort the baby
females from the age about three four
years old will try and take care of
babies
[Music]
that was called a baroo rumble it's a
kind of
like oh poor me
our mother responded with a reassuring
Kurama
see how reaching back there she's trying
to show the baby where to suckle
so even though the aloe mother
is not able to produce milk like Mom
does she does provide comfort
and that forms a close Bond
still making that little sound that's
like I want it's a it's a suckle Rumble
but it's a more complaining one
obviously it's not getting any milk
okay now it's going to Mum
to get some
real milk
Rumble that she puts her leg forward to
let the calf suckle
very cute
[Music]
after decades decoding the calls of
Savannah elephants
Joyce has discovered a language more
elaborate than we ever imagined
foreign
elephants do combine different types of
corals they can combine and make a
rumble raw rumble or a raw rumble or a
rumble trumpet
snort trumpet
what we don't know is whether by
combining
those two different types
they're making in a sense a new word
elephant conversations can be incredibly
complex
all of their rumbles contain infrasonic
components that is below the level of
human hearing
elephants can hear these powerful
rumbles from miles away
and also pick them up as vibrations
through their feet and trunk
because they can back and forth for a up
to an hour
literally having a kind of conversation
they're having a discussion about
something it's very obvious
it's not just noise
it has meaning
[Music]
they're so like us they communicate
about some of the same things that we do
and this communication is part of the
glue that holds the whole family
together
[Music]